today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
convalescent flows with strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection convalescent
[Music]
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescence
convalescent
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive
host an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pakman
he is
[Music]
david pacman he is a pain
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but
whoa whoa jesse will we we gotta that's
a lot
that's a lot we would everything that's
raw abortion they think and act just
like a woman a beta male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is a baby
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we we're
just out of time for that i don't think
we can do too much more of that because
we do have a very very big uh very big
news day we are down to just eight days
remaining before
this election and it is mostly looking
good for joe biden
except where it isn't a couple of spots
where it's not looking good for joe
biden or for example
people who plan to vote but
haven't yet voted in some particular
background states uh
battleground states background
battleground states uh overwhelmingly
leaning in the direction of trump so
when we see the early democratic voting
and the high turnout
we just have to wait we just have to
wait and we have to vote
very very importantly so i still don't
think
again as i've said if you say even money
bet david who do you think wins
i bet biden if you tell me am i as
confident as i would need to be
in order to say don't worry about it i'm
gonna go on vacation for the next eight
days
no no no no not even close uh we were
having
um some conversations so we had we had
this idea
that after the election regardless of
who wins whether it's trump or
biden if it's biden things will start
going back to normal
and just interest in politics will calm
down if trump wins
people will be so depressed that he won
again that people will check out at
least until the midterms
now we've moved it to inauguration day i
think regardless of what happens
if trump wins we're gonna be in spike
three i don't know if you've seen what's
been going on
uh from the standpoint of cases but it
is getting
uh we are again we're not calling this
wave three
but i'm certainly calling it spike three
where we had one spike to about 32
000 cases a second spike to about 70 000
cases we've now had a couple of days as
you can see here records
81 000 in a day 79 000 in a day
even if trump wins it's going to be an
insane transition period and if biden
wins trump is going to absolutely lose
his mind so now we're saying
okay it'll probably be crazy until
inauguration
and then we'll see and after that point
i'm not making any predictions yet but
it's certainly uh something we're gonna
be
uh keeping an eye on uh throughout and
we're gonna be here at least
certainly in this in this last sprint
um and uh we'll we'll be here with you
so today this is going to be donald
trump's third rally of the day this one
is in where the hell is this i don't
even
martinsburg pennsylvania we're awaiting
donald trump's arrival scheduled for the
bottom of the hour
we're monitoring a few different streams
for you but that's where we're waiting
right now
and i have a few different things to go
over with you um
and to discuss i was going to do a map
an electoral map
just to give you guys a sense of how it
could come down to a couple particular
key
states and why those states are so
important and why it's relevant
when those states start counting ballots
hint hint pennsylvania
but let me read a few super chats first
unknown prodigy asking whether i've ever
imagined
that i and anna kasparian would do a
show
that it would be ratings bonanza and we
would get along great i was actually
just emailing with anna the other day
we were actually in discussion this is
breaking news
prior to corvid you all know what i'm
talking about
we were talking very strongly uh
we share uh well should i i guess
we share representation i guess is fair
to say
we were very powerfully looking at
a sort of live event
series let me just put it that way
without saying anything else
then corvid right so um
that's it's not it's not happening for
the time being but i would love to do
something with her in the future we've
been on
politicon stuff together so on and so
forth
michael blanco says david saw today that
a ballot drop-off in boston was set
ablaze hopefully not the one you used it
was not the one i used
and i voted weeks ago but yes we covered
that
story on the bonus show today jennifer
says david orange jesus is in my county
right now in central pa and our coveted
cases are getting bad hospital icu
almost at capacity
this rally will make it so much worse
i'm in the middle of very red area of
the state i
i feel for you um
a user who goes by the name bustanu
i'm going to go with that i'm not stupid
bustanu says next tuesday is my birthday
vote for me please
and uh that's all very very exciting
over on twitch
no messages right now but a few thank
yous emergency alert
thank you for the sub nug wrangler is in
for 14 months and
little plumber girl has also subscribed
and uh yes people wondering if the
discord is working the discord is
working fine we have a new
official david pakman show discord 3 500
or so
people on it as of now davidpakman.com
discord is where you can find that okay
let me briefly okay i've got a couple do
we want to do memes first or my map
first i don't even know
um maybe we'll do
maybe we'll do memes yeah so i've got a
couple little things i requested
a david borat last week and
i got it as you can see here um take a
look at this this is this is pretty wild
this is me as borat i guess walking down
the street
with a mustache as well so
you know that's that and then here is a
pretty good video people made this is
that someone made this who made this
uh scrumptious made this oh wait hold on
this is mike from finland i guess is the
person who made this
this is my frustration with the phone
calls from last week i think you guys
remember this
johnny from boston johnny from boston
what's going on
now boy johnny from boston
can you unmute and talk to me let's go
to rob from virginia
rob from virginia please unmute
let's go to uh mike from finland mike
from finland what's going on
mike from finland what's going on
oh boy mike from finland what is going
on
all right it's holly from australia
kind of odd ah david can you hear me
yes i can okay so there we go uh that's
from
scrumptious which i think is uh very
very nicely done i appreciate that a lot
that's a that's a very very nice one i
really do like that uh
okay stream schedule stream schedule
during the next week well as you can see
donald trump is going to be
in michigan wisconsin and nebraska
tomorrow
and where else was that some other
places i'll be carrying some trump
rallies but i
also am going to be carrying obama biden
events
and unfortunately the biden campaign
does not make it easy to figure out like
when they are doing the rallies so if
anybody
finds out when there is going to be an
obama biden rally or an obiden rally as
some people call them
please email in through my website
contact form and let me know because i
would love to cover those
obama has been triggering i mean just
hot
brutally triggering donald trump and i
look forward to
covering those okay other
super chats coming in uh
let's see what we've got abu
says martinsburg is 15 minutes from
where i am from we cannot afford to have
a super spreader event like this
i'll say tristan says feel like trump
obviously going to steal the election
with the supreme court what is being
done to stop
i i wish i could tell you i wish i could
tell you
kj says oh my god oh my god oh my god
david please please please do a series
with anna it's a-n-a
not a-n-n-a let's let's at least respect
her enough
to spell her name correctly insight of
the ages says any word on biden's
daughter's diary
will you try to verify handwriting
experts have verified
i don't know what the hell you're
talking about we've got eight days
until donald trump might be re-elected
biden's daughter's diary i don't know a
thing about it
i don't know a thing about it tanner
audia
oh wait no i'm sorry michelle phelps
says it's my birthday but you get the
present keep up the good work looking
forward to when political news is boring
again thanks michelle
pinkpoison has subscribed on twitch and
says thanks for keeping me sane and
informed
thank you for being here tanner says are
you streaming election nights
as results come in yes yeah you know i i
really i
i'm gonna stream on election night we're
going to stream results i really have no
idea
whether it's going to be sort of a meh
stream
or whether it's going to be our biggest
stream ever i don't i really don't know
what to expect like
is there going to be more or less
interest in it than
last week's debate which was a record
for us on youtube
or the first debate which was a record
on twitch i really have no idea
but what the hell else am i going to do
i'll be watching
so i will certainly be uh broadcasting
speaking of which okay so let me quickly
now i'm going to do this
i'm doing this um let me do a blank map
i'm doing this like right now i'm going
to talk through it with you
so give me a second if i'm not super
quick i want to put these scenarios
together and show you
what could be some some pretty wild
scenarios so obviously the west coast
uh biden will win alaska trump will win
hawaii biden will win
montana idaho wyoming the dakotas
um nebraska i'm going to go red but i
think that there's a chance
well let me i'll get back to that utah
colorado will be blue
new mexico will be blue sorry about that
oklahoma and kansas red i believe that
trump
will i'm i'm going to assume trump wins
texas if trump doesn't win texas this is
all moot because it'll be a crushing
louisiana arkansas missouri i believe
minnesota
wisconsin actually let me leave those
blank for now illinois will be blue
indiana red
all of these states over here i believe
are going blue
um this here here here
here georgia i think ultimately will be
trump
south carolina will be trump virginia's
going blue west virginia red
kentucky red tennessee this is all going
red
um okay so now let me start figuring out
these
this this is where it gets very very
dicey oh maine i think is going very
good
so um now where was so
imagine that trump gets these states
that he got
in um 2016
and that he gets florida let me actually
go blank on pennsylvania
and he gets north carolina iowa i'm
trying to get this set up the right way
how was okay so this is a scenario
where it all comes down to pennsylvania
okay just to start with this is a
scenario where it comes down to
pennsylvania
pennsylvania of the states that don't
start counting
until the polls close is the only one
that
could oh whoops texas is blue hold on a
second
so hold on this is so this is not the
scenario uh i think i was assuming
this scenario okay i'm sorry guys this
scenario i i again i should have made
notes but i figured i could figure it
out quickly
this is a scenario right here where it
all comes down to pennsylvania
pennsylvania we are not going to maybe
know
for a couple of days because they don't
start counting mail-in ballots
until uh polls have actually closed this
is a scenario where
if trump gets pennsylvania he wins and
if biden gets pennsylvania he wins
this is a real scenario folks where
we actually might not know the results
for a while
but the good news is there are lots of
scenarios
where it's not going to come down to
pennsylvania if
biden gets florida it's probably over
even without arizona or nevada which are
in play
ohio is which is in play north carolina
which is in play
uh conversely if trump gets florida
but biden manages to get arizona and
nebraska
and nevada it's 270 for biden
pennsylvania we may not know for days
but it becomes irrelevant because
biden's got 270
already that's without winning florida
nor ohio so the point that i'm making
is there are a lot of scenarios here now
let me there was one other one that was
interesting which came down to the
second district in nebraska let me see
if i can do this
um where was this
was a very specific scenario where it
could be
where that one nebraska vote could have
been the difference maker
what was it though i should have done
this
was it this way no
this there was just like one state
271 anyway i'm sorry i'm i'm gonna
put this all together in a more
professional manner i understand what
i'm doing now is a mess
but there was a scenario i found which
was not
come this has to be red
what else do i need to flip for that
scenario it's a very interesting
scenario
um would it be this
no was it north carolina
north carolina and maybe anyway
i don't remember guys but the point is
there was a scenario i found where it
was
ultimately it was basically it could be
a tie
uh and then like this one nebraska
district could be the difference maker
or something like that
the point is guys we've got to vote in
every single
every single state every single district
we don't know what's going to happen it
could come down to pennsylvania it
could come down to the nebraska second
district any number of scenarios
any any number of scenarios okay thank
you i apologize
if i flipped north carolina and
pennsylvania that would have worked okay
fair it doesn't even really matter the
point is it exists
it exists so just go and vote
everybody's got to go and vote that's
the the very important point
all right other super chats that are
coming in let me see what we've got here
i don't want to miss anybody um
where is this where did i leave off
um okay i see dead llama says
david my roommate keeps saying my vote
doesn't matter but i tell him if
everyone who said that voted it would
change an entire election but he won't
have it any advice
yeah i might move on to somebody else i
mean at this point how much time are we
going to
spend convincing any one voter we need
more of a wholesale strategy
than a retail strategy if your roommate
still doesn't get it then you know
what can we do grant logan says is shira
on the line
she-ra that was a big line last week
irene says a big hello from canada i
have my fingers and toes crossed that
these early voters are voting biden
harris
hope the usa gets its dignity back you
and me both
insight of the aegis says biden's diary
is unknown to you because the
gaslighters shine a light in a way that
keeps truth in the dark
who is holding your gaslight oh my god i
hope
it's been worth spending 10 bucks here
today ken says the next four to eight
years will be critical for moving
democrats left and strengthening a
left-wing coalition nader wrote about
social democrats greens and libertarians
joining forces to root out plutocracy in
his book unstoppable he did
and and did it did it well kay
says autocorrect my enthusiasm to see
you and anna chat still there
sorry thank you i do really appreciate
that
uh people turning to face us i assume
it's because donald trump's plane is
approaching
um yungi says from the uk what's with
the ymca song i have no idea why trump
plays ymca at every one of these
deranged rallies
i couldn't tell you briannis has been
watching you a while pleasure to have
finally joined can we talk about the
very
multiple coveted spikes following all
the rallies minnesota pennsylvania
wisconsin
you know we can the rallies have been
linked to cases but not a cartoonishly
high number because they
are outdoors outdoors reduces
transmission dramatically
so we have talked about it in minnesota
but for me it's for me the real story is
this administration has continued to
pretend nothing's going on
and we are one of the worst places in
the world to be in terms of per capita
cases and deaths that's really the news
hero shave fur heroes have first a hero
shave
heroes have fur david could you please
address why the dems did not try
impeachment of bar
or trump to slow the scotus nomination
process i don't think it would have
worked
i think that's why most wise one
with the comment about faithless
electors nicholas is david what does all
that polling data mean we should do it
means we should vote
that's it zelda gigafan says i put the
odds of biden winning texas at 40
i think the odds of biden winning texas
are more like 38
37 38 something like that
thanks to house of dub as well as
octalian
for subscribing with twitch prime i
appreciate that
um bay photo says do these trump rally
crowd sizes concern you not kovid but
politically are they more energized than
we
than we think they may be which means we
have to vote
period that that's it i mean yeah we
should be worried about that of course
alex lombardo says thanks for the great
show down with the clown
and james says did didn't trump winning
michigan result from a
mere two-vote lead per precinct armed
with that knowledge
how can anyone say their vote doesn't
matter it is
very dangerous very dangerous this idea
of
anyone's vote doesn't matter and um
you know what i tend to say to people
when they say when has an election come
down to one vote
you know a lot of people have that
thought when has it when what are the
odds my this election comes down to my
vote
if everybody who had that thought stayed
home
then the election comes down to those
people and
uh that's that's the important thing
that's the important takeaway
dominick says if hillary had one would
trump is still claim covet is fake and a
hoax or would they be exaggerating it
they'd probably be exaggerating it yeah
no i think that's i think that's
reasonable
i think that's very very reasonable
um let's see uh we have the obligatory
does david read twitch chat message from
nug wrangler
thanks for getting that in i do read
twitch chat thank you
very very important to check in about
that i do want to say
a huge thank you to christina mesa
who is new member number one today at
joinedpakman.com
also uh gage donovan
gage donovan is new member number two
at joinpacman.com very much appreciate
that
very very much appreciate that uh
okay what else do we have going on
noni says plenty of people are voting in
the triangle
in north carolina is that the knowledge
triangle that's like uh
hold on uh is it asheville chapel hill
and uh what's what's that what's the
triangle remind me the north carolina
triangle that's where like people have
college degrees and stuff right
do i remember that correctly anybody
nobody knows rally
raleigh rally
raleigh durham chapel hill okay the
research triangle beautiful
beautiful very good a ren holder says i
can't wait to never think
about trump again on a different note
you should interview john mcwhorter i
would be interested in that i watched
some of his uh
podcast episodes yeah
um what else do we have here danny says
is there a website out there that lists
state by
state when each state can start counting
ballots whether early in person or male
absentee
there is um yeah i would uh i mean let's
see
when does each state start counting
mail-in ballots i assume it'll be the
first result in google
it is it's a ballot pedia link which
tells you every single state
every single state amazing how quickly
we can find the data that's what we care
about here the data danny you know that
nicholas says thoughts on presidential
candidate kanye west on rogan's podcast
i found it delusional and and again i
think kanye is deeply mentally ill
i think that all of the making fun of
kanye
you know i i really do think the guy uh
has major issues it's not it's not even
funny to me it's just
i see a sick guy i don't know what you
guys
say about that but i just see a sick guy
christy says hope everyone gets a david
cameo video sometime i got one for my
girlfriend a few months ago
where he gave her cat an honorary
membership thanks deepak
you know what's insane every morning
i've been getting up
and i've got i mean okay that's not
crazy that that part's not crazy i think
you would all expect that that happens
but i'll log into my cameo and i have
like five or six cameos waiting it's
crazy
it's mostly birthday shout outs to be
perfectly transparent with you
um all right looks like it's getting
potentially a little rainy
in uh hold on where is the i keep
forgetting where this rally is
martinsburg pennsylvania and people seem
to be paying attention
i guess to the oh the the chopper is
here okay trump taking the chopper i
guess from a nearby airport or
something so we'll be hearing from
donald trump very soon
uh what else do we have
you olga says samantha b did an episode
where she talked to people who lost by
one vote there were
there were more than you could imagine
interesting interesting
all right we are probably just moments
now why are people looking behind is
this the decoy helicopter as many of you
know marine one often flies in groups of
two to four helicopters
in case someone were to target one
helicopter
it would be less likely they get the
right one
uh so i believe that this maybe this is
not maybe people are looking
uh behind the camera oh there are two of
them there all right oh there's a second
one okay
i don't know what's going on maybe
they're waiting for the third or fourth
one we we will see
please consider yourself invited by the
way to grab
a membership at joinpackman.com
as i may have mentioned before our
program
really depends on the support of people
who sign up on my website i'm not asking
for a lot of money
if you hate me if you find me despicable
uh don't even worry about it don't do it
don't don't sign up
uh but if you've got a couple bucks a
month i would love it for you to grab a
membership at joinpakman.com as you can
see the coupon code
2020 now saves you 66
use the coupon code don't use it i
really it really makes no difference to
me
we just want to involve as many people
as possible you've all heard about
youtube adpocalypse and stuff happening
on all these different platforms
um and the best way that we can
protect ourselves from it is to build
our own support on our website join
pacman.com
and um if folks sign up i will give
shout outs and thank yous to the extent
i can
before trump starts let's see what if we
can hear anything here
okay no so they seem to have some kind
of problem by the way
here's an exa this is what we're
fighting okay if you're thinking
i don't know maybe i'll get a membership
maybe i won't let me
play a voicemail for you which will
outline exactly what we're fighting
listen to this
hey danielle prickless you your show
you know what i have to do take that
microphone and show up your ass
what happened to patty you weren't tight
enough
your ass wasn't tight enough for her you
know you flap your
arms around like a little girl like a
wounded bird you look like an
idiot you are an idiot guess what by the
way it's funny to say my
our motions are weird you know trump's
constantly like playing an invisible
accordion
and pointing at people anyway projection
as usual democrats are going down
baby down no matter what you say you
freak
and then this same gentleman so so for
example
that this is an example of what we're
fighting you understand this is why we
you know we we count on
the support of folks who realize you
have to fight that because that guy's
getting those ideas somewhere
here's another one i haven't even
pre-screened this one it could be vile
yeah you freak
do you stick a tampon up your ass after
you
put your microphone up your ass we're
gonna send you a pair of
little lace panties i think you look
good in those
you you swing your arms around like a
stupid bird
stephanie miller could kick your ass and
she's another freaking progressive
guess what supreme court republicans
congress
republicans president
uh republicans okay lost this train of
thought there for a moment
people are going down baby down no
matter how much you cry
little cry babies still haven't gotten
over 2
2019 you idiots
so i'm pretty sure that that's a main
accent
and i i think that that person actually
now they're blocking their number when
they call
but they used to call from a main number
i'm pretty sure i'm pretty sure actually
in fact
i think they're on the fbi's radar to be
perfectly frank i think we we did
forward some of the
other messages on to the fbi so that's
why it's great you know when people like
tristan matheson sign up on my website
or marcel dreschler uh or
wendy hoskins who are new members three
four and five as you can see
that's why it matters because there's
people like that
who are very actively trying to destroy
everything that we're doing um i think i
have one more
just while we're doing this kind of
clear out the computer
um you guys want so jimmy from philly
called in
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
ten times in an hour okay ten times in
an hour i'm sorry no 11.
just let's see what some of these are
[Music]
oh i see he's just calling over and over
but not saying anything
does he actually say anything in any of
these
david tell me from philly right
so you're not talking around class the
[ __ ] going on
what
did anybody understand that what the
hell was that
and there's one more and then one other
one david jimmy from philly wiped
uh what does he is he saying wifed
is he saying jimmy from philly wifed
he's been wifed
yeah yeah our bear should just cover
this fairy cousins in there
fairy dozens did he say how the [ __ ] do
you associate yourself with this
angry [ __ ] associate i can't even
i can't even fake that what is that
that's is that a jersey or philly accent
associate
my mouth won't even do it
i mean david i think you're
smarter and easier to listen to than
this [ __ ] than certainly [ __ ]
but chunk
fairy is just an angry
bald-headed [ __ ] boldhead
stupid [ __ ] like i think he
actually believes the [ __ ] that he's
feeling now okay so anyway
the point is guys when we talk about
membership
that's what we're fighting there are
people who will call our affiliates
and say take david pakman off the air
pressure our affiliates to pull us
there are people who contact our guests
and say please don't appear on david
pakman's
you know all of this stuff uh and that's
that's why
that's why it's so important that we
build a base of support so on that note
thanks to connor johnston for signing up
at joinpackman.com
thanks to jack bhutan for signing up at
joinpackman.com
very very much appreciated and uh
we are of i mean it's just it's just
been been such a crazy year and
thankfully we've
been able to grow grow our support
during the year let me thank a few
people over
on twitch who are sending me messages
mine host has signed up and says hello
from mullengar
i don't know what state or country that
is mullingar
another helicopter showing up crimson
elric has subscribed says david richard
from seattle would love to get sam
harris back on the show
of course let's get trump out first be
well yes my interview with sam harris
did very very well uh would be
interested in having him back on much to
discuss
much much much to discuss uh if you
can't hear me unmute
my audio is working and it is working
perfectly
um all right let me do a few other super
chats my friends because there are more
coming in and i don't i don't i'm going
to try to get to more as we wait for
trump
ubiquitous says voter suppression
includes facebook ads pushing reasons
to not vote biden to progressives they
did it in 16 expect they'll do it again
be vigilant everybody yes be vigilant
t6 says we just got our coveted cases to
zero in melbourne australia after about
120 days of strict lockdown
i am jealous of zero cases i'm very
jealous
mile high hustle says 538 gives biden a
33
chance of winning texas but gives biden
and 87
of winning the whole enchilada baklava
okay very good
uh james says at least trump isn't using
air force one as a backdrop
backdrop yeah i don't think it would be
able to land at this airport
k says australian here i'm so worried
about your election and covid for you
guys i've taken a day off work to
support you all from an
australian supporter thank you
simon says simon from belgium here thank
you for doing what you do david i
appreciate your
sanity during these insane times
i appreciate you appreciating it
okay i just missed a bunch of super
chats here
hold on it scrolls up when a bunch come
in at once
uh youngi says weave rhyming slang in uk
taking a donald is really taking off
over here
jake says everyone hit that like button
and vote
must vote must vote another helicopter
coming by
i'm guessing that that's the full
propaganda where did they land three
choppers
and then now they're bringing number
four by i mean how much fuel are we
wasting here guys holy
um it's just disgusting what is going on
here
page says what should we expect to see
from dems in the event that trump wins
the election but loses control of the
senate along with the house
i am uh i am reading about that now
and i will certainly have a uh a clip
for you
if that scenario happens for the time
being i'm trying to take it a day at a
time the speculation
we've got one goal in front of oh look
at this what on earth is going on
can you believe this insanity
these people oh my god and the cheering
and
it's it we have to end this guys we have
to end this
look at this people waving imagine
waving to trump who's flying over you in
helicopter number four
it's it's vile
uh morph cogan did you read crypto
sponsor vid comments not good
i didn't i didn't i really i
at this point we get 3 000 comments a
day i just don't have there's so many
things going on
broken curtains says statehood for
puerto rico in washington dc
i i agree with you prior guy says get to
de chapa
l diner productions should we be
concerned about trump calling the
election early
yeah i mean we should be as concerned
about that as we are about a lot of
other things that he's doing
ms smith says recent article says
facebook has a favorable view towards
the right wing do you think this is true
listen the right has a very strong
presence
um on uh on facebook and
some of the some of the best performing
sort of political channels on facebook
are right-wing channels
the idea that facebook is you know a
stronghold of left-wing ideology is very
very false very very much false
brandon says i'm shocked you're still
holding these
stream of trump rallies he says the same
crap are you going to stream the whole
thing i don't know this is earlier in
the day so i may stream the whole thing
i may not hopefully it'll start raining
and it won't be that long
that's my that's my preference to be
perfectly frank
thanks to shadowblade hsc mace
and avinari for subscribing over on
twitch
very much appreciate that let me say a
few other new member thank you so i
don't
get people furious with me barry
hamilton
is new member number eight deflated
brady
i like that is new member number nine
louis hurst is new member number ten
giacomo pernigo is new member number
eleven
uh what else do we have here jolie
thatcher is new member number 12 sandra
pavalo thanks for being new member 13.
lynette o'donnell is number 14
andy thatcher is number 15
and gordon justin is new member number
16 today
very much appreciate that we now have
four helicopters
and hopefully trump will be coming out
of one of these it's getting
disgusting here completely disgusting
um jake says went out and voted early
for biden in maryland today if you
haven't already go vote
do it everybody do it pat
says i can't believe we the taxpayers
are paying for this loon to spread the
virus across the country
and spread jet fuel just but with
flyovers
it's it's really gross michelle says he
told his supporters to vote in person
because he planned on disputing all
mail-in ballots in the supreme court on
january 20th can he
i don't believe that will happen no i
don't believe that will happen
um keep up the fight
oh people asking if if you guys broke
the subscribe button during the last
debate
so i told this story during the last
debate
that during the first debate youtube
viewers broke the subscribe button which
means
there's this thing that happens on on
youtube
if too many people subscribe at once to
my youtube channel which is free
youtube uh the algorithm is triggered
kind of like
trump has been triggered by obama the
last few days the algorithm thinks
to the extent that it can think i'm
assigning anthropomorphic
agency to the algorithm but the
algorithm thinks
this many people can't possibly be
signing up for this crappy channel
how nobody whose subscribers to the
pacman channel can't be
so it triggers an algorithm which will
not
show the subscriber numbers and it will
verify them individually over like a
five to seven day period
that happened you that was triggered
during the first debate
and it was again triggered during the
second debate it was insane
uh oh and speaking of which oh i think
people may actually like this
hold on this is a little inside baseball
i got a message
from my youtube rep who said
i wanted to shoot you early data on the
debate stream this is from the thursday
debate stream i think some people will
like this and some people will hate this
they will
you know there's a lot of people waiting
for me to circle the drain and rap
peak concurrent record for the show
56 580
last stream you led
left-wing political publishers
independent political publishers you led
you were the
top channel for the stream you were in
the top
20 streams for all channels
including corporate media in fact i
think you were number 15 or 16
you beat nbc news on peak concurrent
viewers
but they beat you on live views kudos on
a great live stream
guys can you imagine
[Music]
on all we were the number one left
independent streamer
during debate number two and we were
15th
or 16th of all channels
on all of youtube you understand guys
billions and billions of
well okay no millions and millions of
people watching incredible
an incredible day an incredible day so i
appreciate everybody who uh
who participated we are still
waiting for donald trump now 21 minutes
late has arrived after four
helicopters landed we now have trump
let's see if the music is going i'm
guessing it's that lame country song
yeah i only needed a second in order to
realize that
unbelievable um
people asking if i'm gonna do any kind
of among us stuff
i would be willing to do an among us
thing
but only if it's really big you know i
mean the aoc thing
with hassan and pokemane
both friends of the david pakman show it
was it was just unbelievable you know
and i would want to do it doesn't have
to be as big as that but i would want to
do something significant
i don't want to just do it with you know
i want it to be a major event if people
want to help put it together
maybe anthony mellon fantano could be a
participant
i would love it if oh my god someone
handing trump a hat
he almost did he almost just slipped
there that was weird um
oh trump's gonna throw hats out corona
hats okay
uh am i gonna be back on on uh with uh
austin formerly known as raj you know i
i don't know if this
i don't want to um i don't want to
if this is supposed to be a secret i
apologize to austin but austin and i
uh chat one-on-one directly rel
a couple times a week we're talking
about polling and different things going
on in the election he's a good guy and i
would love to do something with him
very very soon very soon big thank you
to claudia kate
for being new member number 17 today
adrian mazur is new member number 18.
jared hunt number 19 shayna sweezie
is new member number 20 and james
thompson new member number 21. i i
so appreciate that let's see if i can
read a couple other super chats here
danielle says david thank you for
keeping me entertained with u.s politics
my boss thinks the u.s could collapse in
my lifetime due to partisanship
well the u.s could i don't know how old
you are but the u.s
could collapse check out my interview
about the fall of rome
um even things that seem uh
you know omnipotent and immortal can
end and you know anybody who thinks
otherwise give me a break
aldemir says as a mainer who's quite
progressive we're not all like that
love you david thank you the caller
is a beta male says
oso all right let's get to trump here
drum
prompt etc very low-key we wanted to
make a low-key appearance
[Applause]
did anybody notice the helicopter flying
a little low and
yeah we did now greatest pilots in the
world greatest equipment in the world
that's right
the greatest equipment in the world but
the greatest pilots
nobody can do what our pilots could do
right mike
yeah hello pennsylvania hello
pennsylvania
eight days from now can you believe it
eight days
started off four years ago remember our
meetings and our
it was a love fest right from the
beginning wasn't it and now it's more so
you know what it's more so than it was
four years ago
and they're gonna be finding that out
very soon
they're gonna be finding it out you know
i have i have the ratings
oh no not the polls
poll numbers thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
this is ridiculous
you know joe biden you know sleepy joe
biden said a little while ago he was
he was in a lid you know what a little
garbage can they put the lid on it they
put them
yeah biden's in a garbage can two of
these today there were fantastic
different parts of the commonwealth of
pennsylvania right
and we had two events sleepy joe was
down there and they said you've got to
get out of this baby joe
so he traveled from delaware to a little
tiny corner of pennsylvania like right
next to delaware
and he made a speech and he said that he
doesn't do these kind of rallies
because right that's right yeah now he
doesn't do that because nobody shows up
just like he wore a mask which trump
made fun of as well
kovind kobe komen that's all they talk
about the fake news kovitkova 230 000
deaths all they talk about
what progress we've made on it too we
understand it
we know we have to protect our seniors
especially when they have heart
when they have diabetes problems if you
have heart attack
you must be protected in the world
that's why we show so many cases because
we do more testing than anybody else
but we're doing great and uh so i have
to mute because this is so important
um testing is up four percent over the
last week case is up 21
so it is false that we are simply seeing
more cases because of more testing
testing up four
cases up 21. please great and uh
i said what's the story doc sir you've
tested positive i said positive for what
doc tell me
and you know idiocy and corvis president
if you're doing your job you can't stay
in the basement of the white house
you can't stay in a basement you can't
stay in a beautiful bedroom upstairs
you can't do that you got to do your job
and i i'd have many days i'd say
i met a lot of people today there's got
to be something going but one day they
came back
and these doctors were so great and
there are a lot of them there's so many
doctors you know when you're
president there's so many doctors yeah
why is anybody worried about coronavirus
you catch it you'll get 20 doctors to
fly in from john
johns hopkins and give you five
treatments it's fine guys there's
different parts of the body
and they would grab my body and i hated
it
i said get your hands off me doctors but
let's make me feel good and we
took something that was like incredible
regeneron
and i don't know maybe i would have just
been perfect just by doing nothing but
who the hell wants to take a chance
and i woke up the next morning and i
felt like superman
get me back get me back let me back
and the first lady had it right first
lady had it
where has she been by the way she's
great she's and she is popular too
people like her they love they love
melania but she had it
doesn't complain about things and then
of course
baron had it now with baron you know
young
strong commune system he had it i said
what's the story doc with baron sir he
tested positive
like 15 minutes later how's baron doing
sir it's gone
so you have to get back to school we
have to get back to school
pennsylvania you know you have a
governor
you have a governor
[Applause]
you have a governor who doesn't you know
want
us to do anything in pennsylvania
because
did you see the poll just came out we're
up to and another one we're up for
[Applause]
because you watch i have a whole list of
the polls that just came out
but eight days from now we're going to
win the commonwealth of pennsylvania and
we're going to win
four more years in our great white house
let's hope not
just a few hours from now the senate
will vote to confirm
judge amy coney barrett to the united
states
supreme court that was a good choice was
it i've never seen any
[Applause]
i'm glad she's not running for president
i'd much rather go against sleepy joe
much easier now she's fantastic a
fantastic person fantastic woman
a great student her professor her great
professor at notre dame said
and he's been teaching a long time a lot
of great legal minds he's taught he said
she's the single
greatest student he's ever had that was
good for me that was a
highly respected person god he's a
highly respected man he said sir she's
the greatest student i've ever had
judge barrett is one of our nation's
most brilliant legal minds she'll defend
our rights our liberties and our
god-given freedoms that i'm not sure of
sir i don't know about that and we were
all watching a great amusement as she
was so-called grilled by the opposition
that was easy right
that was easy that was like one of our
great football teams from the area
plenty of them
playing a high school football team that
was really something
judge barrett will be the third supreme
court justice
along with almost 300 right around the
number
by the time we end the first term
i'll have 300 maybe a little more maybe
a little less federal judges
that we've confirmed to uphold our laws
and are that's a tragedy
that's a real tragedy and part of that
was that barack hussein obama
here we go 142. he's been doing the
hussein thing a lot
of 142 empties i don't think anybody's
ever had one you don't do that
but he left me 142 couldn't get him
confirmed
to this day called the republican
senator to release his list of names
got to live you know it's more than just
a pack in the court
he's got to say who's he going to put on
because we can't have
radical left justices that are going to
destroy our nation
and we will be very very careful as to
who we choose you know i left a list of
45
i had a list of 25 and now i added 20
names to all
top scholars 45 anybody tracking the
math here amy was one of them
took amy off and the fact is you have no
idea a lot of people say i won because
of the supreme court because
they didn't know who i'd pick and i gave
a list and i said i'll pick somebody
like this
and then they said that's not good
enough got to pick somebody
that's certainly untrue so ultimately
it's a list of 25
all great scholars all people that
believe in something known as
the constitution if that's okay
[Applause]
i don't think his list will and
they say that that was a big part of the
reason that we won the election four
years ago
and he has to do the same thing he's got
to not only agree to not pack the court
or you can't put him on it would be
terrible terrible you know the thing is
biden doesn't have to do anything he can
do whatever he wants maybe people will
vote for him maybe he won't
they won't number we have a senate we
have a house a lot of people
nine is the right number nine great
people that's the right number
but he's got to agree to not pack the
court but he's got to agree to give us a
list of five or 10
or 20 or 30 or 40. gotta have people to
pick from
and if you don't have that list you
can't vote for him and you can't vote
for him for another reason
because during the debate i'm sure
nobody watched the debate did anybody
watch it
remember the last question it was like
perry mason it was just like perry mason
it was at the end he was doing great
this guy was doing so wonderful not
really i mean yeah
meaning he was getting through what and
then the last one i said
uh so you don't want oil joe well
uh yes we want to get ourself off of oil
that's great kristen who i thought
treated me good i really did i thought
she
compared to chris wallace much better
right
chris wallace i was fighting two people
but no i thought she treated us good and
frankly
she went in and she said why did you say
that to him
and that's when he really blew it so
basically he's not going to allow you to
frack and you have a million jobs
i wish that were true probably more than
that and it's a big part of our nation
what you do
people don't realize that about
pennsylvania but fracking is a very big
deal
who are you pointing to
[Applause]
oh oh
oh look at that whoa
oh boy the coal miners right the cold
what's going on there
dig we must dig we must clean coal i
don't call it
coal i call it clean call that stupid
name for it but that's what he calls him
remember when hillary she said we will
stop
all colemans we will never dig call
again
and then four weeks later she ended up
in west virginia that did not work out
well for her
that was not good remember she was
trying to explain that she was just
kidding
just like just like he's doing just like
sleepy joe's doing he was just kidding
but he's down and if that doesn't win us
but
we just had a poll come out we're plus
two now you know we but we should be a
lot more
where this is not a serious person i
hope you guys realize who i don't like
it's an honor you do a great job dig we
must dig
wema
[Applause]
and we brought it back we're selling now
call to vietnam and
trump's selling coal are you coal miners
from pennsylvania
good good that's good well you're not
going to be voting for
joe biden that i can't tell you
not like he's a sophisticated
environmentalist he was told to do this
right biden's and gloom and
unsophisticated
decline in despair our agenda is one of
unlimited optimism we want to be
optimistic remember during the debate
he said it will be a dark winter no
it's going to be a beautiful winter it's
going to be a beautiful spring
okay our country is coming back stronger
than anybody would have thought
and you have to get your governor to
open up your state what this guy is
doing
you know we had one site where we had a
site it was a big site beautiful site
and he made sure that they didn't do it
we had to go around
scouting out for sites on our first this
is my third one all in pennsylvania
but this governor but we're going to
remember it but the problem is how is he
going to be the one when he tries to
play games with sides
that counts ballots right he counts
ballots sites
and then they should just because they
didn't want to have poll watches you
know what a poll watcher is
they watch you count the votes what's
wrong with that if you're doing it
straight
so we're in court and we had a trump's
talking about
random people showing up who said oh you
shouldn't have
poll watches can you believe that we
actually lost the first case but
we'll go up and we'll end up in the
supreme court
the other thing they want to be able to
drag out the election long beyond the
third
well in all fairness that's not true
it's just if your vote's postmarked by
the third it should count and we can't
drag it out we don't want to drag out
any longer so we are in lots of court
having to do with this
many courts with many states about five
much court and so far we've had a lot of
good victories that will continue
because we're not going to let
this election be taken away from us
that's the only way they're going to win
it
we're not going to let it happen what he
means is we're going to take it away for
the last half century
47 years joe biden has been outsourcing
your jobs
opening your borders and sacrificing
american blood and treasure
ridiculous endless foreign wars
countries you've never even heard of for
the most part
now joe biden is trying to ban fracking
and deliver an economic death sentence
for pennsylvania's energy sector you
can't you can't allow this to happen
but here's the thing for you this is the
death sentence right here there will be
no fracking right we saw
with the democrats right oh erratic nine
more people died while we were just
talking about all screaming no fracking
every one of them they couldn't scream
loud enough
then he gets the nomination because
elizabeth warren pocahontas refused to
get out
oh had she gotten out that crazy bernie
would have been our opponent
but i think i like joe better because
there's no energy
i liked you no bernie had a little
energy small base lots of energy and we
had a lot of his
people you know a lot of them with
crooked hillary
bernie he gets i i won't use it because
they have very young people here
he gets taken advantage of by hillary
and then he gets taken advantage of by
the democrats the last time with
mostly elizabeth warren and the others
they ganged up on him
and he goes back and he goes into the
senate i think he's the greatest loser
he's a really good
he's a good loser he's a good sport
crazy bernie okay and in the last week's
debate
joe biden confirmed his plan to abolish
the entire
u.s oil industry smoothly back on the
prompter there
why are you doing this because she's on
his side you know
because that's nbc owned by concass
c-o-n
not com c-o-n so she's on her side
she's saying why are you doing this if
you really look it's almost pleading
sir why are you doing this and i'm sure
just be quiet chris
that's what happens that's right that's
what happened to perry mesa remember the
guy
trump regularly tells women to be quiet
yeah and at the end i did it i did it it
was that was
sleepy joe that's what i you don't need
a president like that
that means no fracking no natural gas
no call no jobs no energy
no pennsylvania families being well
taken care of
fracking is saving pennsylvania families
2 500 a year at least
and it's saving families all over the
country we are energy independent and
your fracking has saved countless lives
yeah
there you go they want to go to wind do
you love wind a nice windmill right
alongside your house your house is now
worthless
you know when those windmills go up and
they're near your house i know a lot
about wind
oh my god many many many times
the energy that we're talking about this
guy's really an idiot or a liar or both
32 cents versus three cents whether it's
natural gas or other things but
many many times but you put up a
windmill
if you want to see a bird graveyard go
under a windmill somewhere here we go
we'll see a grave
remember guys random cats walking around
kill exponentially more birds than any
windmill
and by the way how many birds are killed
because of pollution how many birds are
you understand right
he wants wind and he wants solar i like
solar too but it still isn't developed
and solar's not going to power your big
powerful plants
which we have to have in order to
compete and beat the rest of the world
it's just not going to do it and neither
is wind
looking he will eradicate pennsylvania
energy production and send your state
into a crippling depression that's what
it's going to be because energy's such a
big
people just don't know that mike about
pennsylvania it's a big
big energy state be amazed you know it's
funny texas so
he's against oil he's against gun second
amendment
and he's against god so he goes and then
they say
president trump is four points up in
texas and the governor calls me from
texas great guy greg he said
sir that's not true you're up no you
might be losing
but think of it you're against oil we're
in texas
you're against oil you're against god
you're against guns
in texas guns in texas trump is up four
points it's a very close race
no no same thing here because you have
the same thing and you could really say
the same thing
almost to a little bit lesser extent but
the texas was just amazing
the texas i said at the end texas and
pennsylvania i hope you're looking
and i hope you're listening and that
goes for ohio and it goes for oklahoma
and it goes for a lot of other places
what on earth
so you know we had polls because the
fake news is always giving fake numbers
you know here we go
they're really called this suppression
suppression he'll give us the real
numbers
here they are all brand new uh raspberry
said did you have any of your friends
it's already funny so over there we're
at 53
and 52 that means it's hard to lose you
when you're at 53 or 52.
so rasmussen where and that's national
that's not
you know what i'm doing i go to places
like hillary used to campaign
in california when it doesn't matter
although if i were california i'd vote
for trump because
the place is going to hell this says
48-47
i would vote for trump i would vote for
trump
taxes are too high crime is too high new
york
taxes are too high people are fleeing
crime is too high
i put out vote for trump remember
african-american i said the same thing
vote for trump
what the hell do you have to lose that
was last election
now we are doing so incredibly well he's
pulling eight percent with black
americans black community
eight percent the hispanic community a
little better with hispanics oh it's
unbelievable
they get it because we did criminal
justice reform we did prison reform we
did the historically black
colleges and universities what we've
done opportunity zones with the great
tim scott
senator from south carolina we've done
so much
and now the black community is strong
with us we had a poll today
at strong 40 40. nobody knows what that
means
what nobody knows what that means that's
a number that nobody's heard of with
respect to the republican we should be
much higher than that
he thinks 40 percent of the black vote
he's getting globalist who wiped out
your
delusionals close down your factories
kill your call
jobs outsourced your industries and
supported
every terrible and disastrous trade deal
for more than 47 years he was a
cheerleader for nafta
one of the worst trade deals ever made
by the way usmc just kicked in
it's great yeah look at how great
everybody's doing
your companies aren't going to be moving
to mexico or canada anymore see
yeah i see people bailing because they
can't take it anymore i got you swizzle
swizzle
biden enthusiastically voted for china's
entry into the world trade organization
decimating your manufacturing and
enriching
china at your expense and you were
really one of the biggest victims this
state
you lost 50 of your manufacturing jobs
after biden's nafta and china disasters
they were disasters
he signed it along with other people but
he was one of the people that
pushed what a loon decade after decade
vote after vote
sleepy joe biden has betrayed
pennsylvania you know that
he repeatedly tried to cut social
security and medicare you didn't know
straight up lie
never happened and that was bernie
sanders is the one that exposed him on
that
now after years of economic treachery
he wants to ban fracking and he's going
to and what about his running mate his
wonderful running mate
yeah they asked her about fracking she's
only said about 300
times it will never be fracking now she
said no
joe wants it fracking but she said it
was that brac
she came first no she's nothing special
she never was
i can't believe she was picked actually
nobody treated him worse than her
plus she was a disaster her poll numbers
were going so bad
she left before iowa right before the
vote her post she started off at like 12
and then she went to 10 went they went
backwards the x axis which is where the
time goes time went backwards
went to one went to zero then she said i
think i'm going to get out of the race
and she treated him so badly what she
called him and everything else
and then he said i'd like to announce
that i'm going to pick
kamala oh no
not the gregorian chanting again you
don't have to take my word
we have joe on tape now i only do this
one and the location's very important to
me
because this thing cost a fortune
putting up this tape okay
but look at this crowd so you can oh
he's bringing videos go ahead please
roll the video
my problem is i voted for nafta i'm
supporting nafta
because i think it is a positive thing
to do and i do not pretend to be an
expert on
international trade matters when you ran
for president and when barack obama ran
for president you both said you would
renegotiate nafta
you didn't trade agreements like nafta
and permanent normal trade relations
with china which forced american workers
to compete against people making pennies
an
hour has resulted in the loss of 160 000
jobs the president is
absolutely right when he says that china
has been cheating for 25 years
and that bill clinton didn't do enough
about it george w bush didn't do enough
about it barack obama didn't do enough
about it what
how exactly are you going to negotiate
that what magic wand do you have
the rising china is an incredibly
positive development
for not only china but the united states
and the rest of the world
rising china is a positive positive
anyone in the crowd what aspects are naf
of nafta are bad for them
and they would not be able to explain it
to you i'm not defending nafta but i'm
pointing out that
trump has used this because people don't
know what the hell's going on
that's how he can get away with this
stuff as our competitor
we should be helping the idea that china
is going to eat our lunch
is bizarre the idea is
china is going to eat our lunch come on
man they're not bad folks folks china's
not a problem
allowing china into the world trade
organization which he supported
extending most favored nation status to
china which he supported
that those steps allowed china to take
advantage of the united states
by using our own open
trade deals against us oh do you think
in retrospect look at the well-behaved
cultists watching the video today we're
finally ending the nafta nightmare and
signing into law
the brand new u.s mexico canada
agreement
ask anyone in the crowd the differences
between
nafta and usmca and how that affects
jobs in their county i mean i just just
ask them i dare you
as president and this administration it
is a huge deal
wage growth is better than it has been
since 2009.
that means it is better than it has been
for seven out of eight of the years that
obama was president
the new usmca has powerful protections
to keep
auto manufacturing jobs since the
election we've created
41 000 brand new motor vehicle and parts
jobs
but doesn't he deserve some credit for
that it's better the us mta is better
than nafta
it is better than nafta
never said i oppose frackie you said it
on tape
i did show the tape put it on your
website i'll put it on put it on the
website
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal
and fracking in a biden administration
no it would be we would we would work it
out we would make sure it's eliminated
i guarantee we're gonna so that's that
was obviously cut deceptively what
biden's talking about is phasing it out
over time
which i agree with it's a great
gradually move away from frackie
and i think it's critically important on
day one literally half second video
clips
lisa's on public lands like what about
say
stopping cracking and stopping pipeline
infrastructure
they want to do the same thing i want to
do they want to face some of these are
cut
midward there's no question i'm in favor
of banning fracking
i have one final would he close down
or would you close down the other way i
would transition from the oil industry
yes
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you remember that
pennsylvania oklahoma
what are they even cheering about this
is a cult guys
oh my god
what are they even cheering for
so you never heard me say that that i
can tell you
now isn't that great it's a very
expensive deal but
it saves me a lot of work because
there's nothing does it better than that
right
a vote for biden is a vote to offshore
your jobs
ban fracking and deliver economic ruin
to pennsylvania and to your families
in 2016 pennsylvania voted to fire
this corrupt far-left political
establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who is finally putting america first
[Applause]
with your vote we will continue to fight
for american workers
lower drug prices you know what we're
doing on drug prices
had the first year and fifty years two
years where drug prices came down
you don't even know just last year but
we're doing favored nations so we pay
the lowest in the world right now we pay
the highest
and the drug companies don't like me too
much i can tell you that they're
spending more on advertising than sleepy
joe
support our police protect our second
amendment which is under siege
police defend our borders maintain
energy
independence and ensure more products
are proudly stamped
with that beautiful phrase made in the
usa
right trump's own campaign gear made in
china
epic job growth a safe vaccine that
quickly ends the pandemic and we're
rounding the turn they hate it when i
say it
record cases 48 hours ago it's gonna be
great
record we have numerous companies all
great ones but we're rounding that turn
anyway we're rounding the turn we
understand the disease
we closed it up the greatest economy in
history we closed it up we saved two
million lives remember it was going to
be 2.2 million lives
we saved 2 million lives and we're
rounding the turn normal life
that's what we want normal life
we'll fully resume we'll never forget
what china did to this country or what
china did to the world
and next year will be the greatest
economic year in the history of our
country
and that's where we're heading if you
look at the job numbers
[Applause]
automobile numbers if you look at
housing i gave working families
record-setting tax cuts
and in my second term i will cut
middle-class
taxes even further let's give you the
largest
tax cut only if you vote for them
largest tax cut in history this is the
craziest campaign
right so all my life i watch politicians
running they always say
we are going to cut your taxes right
we are going to cut your i got a guy
running now
who sort of shot he goes we
will raise your taxes i say what the
hell tax cut for the bottom 95
under biden yeah he's going to give you
the biggest tax cut
in the history of our country including
regulations and all the other stuff
which made it so good for us
this election is a choice between a
trump
super recovery or a biden super
depression and that's what you're gonna
have you're gonna have a depression if
you go with this guy
it's a choice between a boom and a
lockdown he wants to lock down your
country you're already locked down he
hasn't said that with your governor
wolf governor wolf has a beauty for you
sure governor we trust you to count our
ballots governor we trust you
and it's a choice between the rule of
the people
or the rule of the corrupt political
class of joe biden and the democrat
socialists
and that's where you're heading and i
always said
this country will never be a socialist
country
never ever what a meaningless statement
but if joe biden and his democrat
socialists are elected
they will delay the vaccine delay the
therapies
prologue the pandemic clothes why would
he do that those are already closed open
them up open up those
understand trump simultaneously says if
if trump loses on november 4th all of
this stuff
ends because it's only political and
he's saying
if trump loses biden will extend
lockdowns
delay treatment delay therapy what what
just before november 3rd of 35
nothing ever even close i think your
record is eight percent
eight percent nine percent 35
and he wants to close it down not a good
idea jill
biden says he has a plan for the virus
and he doesn't he
just copied you see what he did he
copied our plan it's the same plan he
copied he's copying me
everything he's proposed my
administration has already done
including mass production of rapid tests
and
pp we've done pee-pee they've done ppp
the ventilators is incredible
this we weren't prepared with
ventilators our hospitals didn't have
them
our governments didn't have them our
federal government didn't
we went into a production of ventilators
the likes of which
they've never seen anything like it
since the end of world war
ii biden doesn't know how to defeat a
pandemic
his own chief of staff said that when he
managed the h1n1 which he always
reverses
swine flu you know the swine flu a much
less
much less lethal flu which is why it was
handled differently of course
he said quote we did everything possible
and we did everything possibly wrong
we were a disaster 60 million americans
got
h1n1 in that period of time it was like
the flu
purely fortune that it wasn't a mass
casualty
he said we didn't know what the hell we
were doing now this guy comes in
he should have closed it down sooner but
two and a half months later he was
saying i shouldn't have done
the ban to china i shouldn't have done
the ban to europe
if the h1n1 had the same fatality rate
as the china virus
over two million people would have
already passed
the whole point is it was different it
was a disaster and his own
person this is like saying if colds were
100 lethal the whole country would be
dead and it would have been biden's
fault
what are you talking about dude he can't
help himself
in an interview that aired last night
biden said he opposes letting young
americans
resume their lives which was an
interesting statement
99.98 of those under the age of 50
recover and most recover very quickly
but biden wants to keep them
locked down in their homes while letting
riders and looters run wild
so in pennsylvania you can't go to
church
you can't go to restaurants it reminds
me of that funny video if my
if my grandmother had wheels she would
be a bicycle
well but that's not the case that's why
we call everything a friendly protest
that way we're allowed to be
think of it you can't go to church but
if you want to burn down
center city we have no problem with it
i'll tell you
we're bringing our country back but do
you think it's easy with these people we
have to deal with
the biden lockdown would crush america
and my plan will crush the virus and
we're going to have a boom like you've
never seen before why hasn't he crushed
it yet then
like you've never seen before
when the china virus arrived we moved
heaven and earth to fight the disease
we banned all sorts of things everything
we could band we airlifted
medical supplies built hospitals from
scratch
look what we did in new york the
convention center 2
800 beds then we put in the ship
unfortunately governor cuomo barely used
it
if he would have used it for our great
seniors he wouldn't have caused the
death of 11
000 people seniors would love to hear
trump address the stock market today
slash red tape pioneered groundbreaking
therapies
reduced the fatality rate 85 think of
that
i think think of it i mean look at
regeneron for me
and by the way we're going to make
regeneron available to anybody that
feels they want it need it
same as i have free free and the
vaccines that are being produced it's
not your fault it's china's fault
we're not forgetting and the vaccine is
going to be free it's going to be
distributed free to everybody
everything's free all of a sudden a
million doses of a safe vaccine before
the end of the year may be quite a bit
sooner than that
seniors will be the first in line for
the vaccine
and our frontline workers too i will
break through
every obstacle which we've already done
use every resource and i will not
rest until we eradicate this disease
that should have never
he will break through every obstacle
which he's already done well aren't they
broken then already
[Applause]
never forget we will vanquish the virus
and we will emerge better
stronger and more unified than ever
before
if biden and the democrat socialists are
elected
they will raise your taxes to a level
that you've never seen before
is there even one socialist on the back
dismantle your police departments
dissolve our borders they don't want
borders they want open borders they even
said maybe we'll take down the wall
which is now
complete you know the wall is almost
complete yeah
border patrol i said give me the best
it's almost done
i said let me use concrete plank i want
to use concrete plank it's quick and
it's cheap
they said sir we can't do that we need
steel concrete and then
we borrow i said that's great we gave
them everything they wanted
we're now beyond 400 miles and it'll be
finished very soon
right
who could possibly believe that it used
to be all about the wall they never
thought i'd get it bill
used to be all about the walker there's
no wall democrats would do anything not
to have remember
all the work and everyday front page the
war will not happen it will not happen
and it has now that it's almost finished
you don't hear about the wall anymore
right they don't talk about
the fake news media doesn't talk about
look at how many there are these are
lies
that's a lot of valuable equipment this
is an authoritarian telling you a wall
exists that doesn't exist while
attacking the media
and mexico is paying for the wall by the
way because you had any questions
of course they're not so now they know
it's built of course but mexico will not
be paying for i said no no mexico is
paying for the wall okay but
they'll figure that out very soon
they'll confiscate your guns terminate
religious liberty and destroy the
suburbs
all lives the suburbs you must love me i
can tell you
i'm saving you something i'm saving
i got rid of the regulation that was
going to destroy yourself
deep mental illness here unless you like
crime which you don't like right
now they were doing a new thing about
three four weeks ago they said
suburban women don't like trump
he's losing suburb i said why wait
but that's only because i know two
things about
suburban women they don't want a
regulation that is brutal
and a hundred grand is enough to get
them to quiet down he's experienced okay
they don't want that a project we call
it a project and they don't want
crime in the suburbs and you know antifa
antifa says that's the next place they
want to head
they're not heading to the suburbs the
organization antifa it's board decided
as soon as i say go to the suburbs they
want law
order they want safety they want to have
their families be safe
and then they say about i think we're
going to do very well with suburban
women we have a lot of suburban women
right here
got rid of a regulation and ben carson a
great guy said well sir you know be a
lot easier if we just amended it
less onerous it's horrible it's horrible
with your zoning and they've changed
your zoning and you can do whatever you
want and
ruin everything i said no ben let's
terminate it well but if we do it'd be
easier now he's the terminator
let's just terminate it i said uh do it
he said that's a tough one but we'll do
it and we terminated it it's gone
now if if sleepy joe comes back you know
who's going to be in charge of it cory
booker is going to be in charge
that's interesting that would be
interesting the mayor of former mayor of
newark new jersey who never lived in
newark
i don't know how he got away with that
one mike never lived there who's mike
will censor you cancel you and
indoctrinate your children with
anti-american lives but we don't let
that
we don't let that happen you saw that
two weeks ago joe biden has made
a corrupt bargain in exchange for his
party's nomination
he has handed control of his party over
to the rage
phil socialists marxists and left-wing
extremists right because joe doesn't
have a clue let's not kid ourselves
joe how you doing joe not well oh i got
to tell you wait wait wait
so the polls right so winning 52
and 53 right and that's national that's
almost as you know it's crazy as it is
it doesn't mean anything
nevada trump is up by two texas
trump is up by four much more than four
remember
so the polls he's selecting aren't even
accurate according to god
i'm on their side he's on the other side
[Applause]
so let me ask you maybe even more so
that if a candidate is running in texas
and he said we are against oil i think
that's it right
i like this super chat suburban women
needs to be the next joseph woodward
track
i think that that would be great joe if
you're on stream that's a great request
it's terrible it really is terrible ohio
we're up big ohio the great state of uh
[Applause]
we have great people in ohio jim jordan
do we like jim jordan
oh my god horrible ncaa wrestling champ
people don't know that about jim you
know about james not a lot they don't
know about jimmy wrestling a real tough
guy and a great guy
florida we're up four just came out
just came out rasmussen let's look at
florida's average we're up very nicely
four or five but we're really up much
more than that don't forget
if we're up four add it up four five six
seven to it
so from all these polls trump mentioning
this one arizona
we're up in arizona we're up in iowa
we're up big in montana while montana
were up really big
we're up in utah and we're up 22 points
in west virginia west virginia
oh but you don't hear this one imagine
things going so poorly that a republican
has to talk about west virginia polling
dishonest people but that's okay
they were dishonest last time too worse
actually right but you got to get out
you got to get out and vote we got to
put this thing away we win pennsylvania
we win the whole ball game
not true not true
he probably needs it so just you know
you're known as a late
voting state right very late which is a
good thing
who is going to vote soon
imagine if half the crowd's not even
born november 3rd
yeah you're a one of the few right yeah
you want you like
you don't like a ballot sent out and
then thrown into a garbage now
you know you're known for it's called
smart people
who is going to vote for sleepy joe
biden
only if you have the courage only if you
have the courage to raise your head
please don't do it please
who is going to vote for president could
be killed in that crowd
[Applause]
all right now we're going to have a big
you know they call it the great
red wave and they're waiting for it you
know all these ballots came pouring in
these crazy ballots are pouring in from
all over they send the ballots out
nobody knows who said remember guys when
trump talks about a red wave
we just say let's vote they want to have
a thing let's vote
we'll see the numbers in eight days you
know minor things no need to argue with
anybody just vote but they're gonna have
a wave and they're all saying about the
red wave but i think the great
let them say it's gonna be much bigger
than people have any understanding about
i think i think but you hear those
numbers you don't hear those numbers
when you watch the fake there's a
suppression
they want to make you nice and depressed
so you take your wife or husband you say
you know i really like the president but
he can't win because i listen to
fake cnn or i listened to fox fox
by the way fox has the worst polls of
all and they had four years ago do they
have the worst
i said they have the worst you hear that
john roberts who i like a lot
they have the worst he's right there hi
john
they have the worst pollster of anybody
fox is terrible
that's actually not true box polling is
okay
and you say let's go to dinner darling
and then we'll go home and
sadly we'll watch television and my wife
said sir everyone said no we're not
going to dinner we're going to vote
right hillary with her statement about
the deplorables right the deplorables
he's speaking to him right now
that was incredible was that incredible
when she said that who would have
thought that was so bad it was the
probes
she actually said a worse word than that
right the irredeemables remember she
said
the deplorables and the irredeemables i
thought irredeemable we'll find out if
they're redeemable momentarily but it
didn't catch on the thing that caught on
was deplorable and the next day i was
making a speech like this
and it came out it came out we are
deplorable
and they came out by the millions she
was right
i would rap if i were him
the fake news you know every time that
happens and now it's happening with
biden because that's a crime family
frankly
but every time that happens when they
say lock her up lock him
they always blame me and i have nothing
to do with it i'd mention the name and
the place goes crazy they said
you incited that i said i didn't even
talk about it you see that
fake show last night 16 minutes i did a
good job it's a fake show
it doesn't exist hostile attacked by a
woman that do nothing
about women's the flag burning radicals
stupid woman you know
you're running your government you know
that look at portland
we want to go into portland so you know
we did a great job
if you look at seattle we said we're
going in
and the night before they said okay
we're leaving now
because you know we have to be aston the
federal government has to be asked
and then we did a great job in minnesota
minneapolis he's so relatable guys just
like the average guy who works in a
factory can really relate to this
he would have saved a lot of distraction
remember the cnn anchor velci
he said msnbc riots because it's bad for
them you know
we are here in a peaceful demonstration
and behind him right over here the
entire city is burning down
right they had a fire that looked like
berlin
on its worst day the whole place was
burning down
and then he said the military has formed
well it was
you know it was a great group of people
you saw that the national guard
and it was one two three all of a sudden
they started
one line two lines and they just marched
forward
that tear gas didn't velcia get hit on
the knee with tear gas and he went down
they said he's down velci i don't even
know who the hell velche is i just
remember
did a little shave job on his head i was
thinking about doing it
so he's talking about ali who works for
msnbc
and laughing i guess about the fact that
ali got hit
he got hit on the knee with tear gas
right and he went down how funny
and he uh he was not the bravest guy but
i'll never forget the scene of him
saying
this is a friendly protest and behind
i'm telling you i never saw fire like
that it was the craziest thing
but we did a great job we sent in the
national guard and the national guard
it was over in what half hour max they
just started walking
world's most expensive uniforms their
helmet cost
like a giant computer they just and
and you know there was something very
nice about it after watching what went
on for
it was heartwarming but all of it we
could solve it all all they have to do
is ask us the federal government is
waiting and it's always run by democrats
new york problem run by democrat chicago
problem
how do you like her as a mayor is she
wonderful run by democrats all run by
democrats
this election day the people of
pennsylvania need to defy the corrupt
media
the big tech machines and you look at
what they're doing they're protecting
they won't write anything negative about
a man who is corrupt they won't write
there is
nothing they will allow to go in they
should cover trump's corruption more
that's true
and hold you back it's the most
incredible thing and i give great credit
to the new york post who endorsed me
today by the way
what a shock what a surprise
because they're the only one with the
courage to do it and they're out there
it's great what they're doing you must
stop the anti-american radicals from
doing what they're doing you can't let
the democrats and joe biden
have a far-left victory this has to be a
thundering defeat
not just a defeat it has to be a rebuke
a rebuke of socialism
[Applause]
and as corrupt as he is and all the
things he's
his son is like a vacuum cleaner let me
follow you into
china dad dad i'm going to be managing
one and a half billion dollars have you
ever done it before so no i haven't dad
i have no idea they've never done a deal
like that china doesn't do that they
don't give other people money to manage
but you know the scary part is that
remember the big guy gets 10
right the big guy he's the big guy i
don't think he's the big guy the big guy
gets 10
and the big one with china was they
wanted 10 million dollars a year
for introductory purposes so 10 million
i wonder what that was all about that
sounds like a reasonable number then
ukraine
183 000 a month to sit on a board
of an energy company with a questionable
reputation
sit on the board and he has absolutely
no knowledge of energy this young person
sitting right here
very young knows more about energy then
where's hunter
oh my god hunter's real first name is
where where's hunter
remember we made the t-shirt
the jokes to send your jobs to china
while his family rakes in millions and
millions of dollars from the
chinese communist party oh they want him
to win
can you imagine i'm charging him
billions of dollars in tariffs
joe said he would take those tariffs off
remember american companies pay the
tariffs the farmers in iowa nebraska all
of the farmers
because they were targeted and joe wants
to take the tariffs off i gave him
remember i i 25 dumped steel they were
killing our steel companies
25 and our steel companies have been
doing great now
if biden wins china wins when we win
america wins
if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician all right he's now
going into the standard washington
politician line so i think we've gotten
a sense
it is a very similar rally to ones we've
been seeing over the last couple of
weeks
but a little bit more unhinged a little
bit wackier a little bit more
out of control and uh i i think that
that's where we're going to leave it i
see that interest is starting to wane a
little bit
and this is probably probably enough
so i will be covering subsequent trump
rallies this week
also i'm very much looking forward to
the obama biden rallies barack obama out
very strongly for joe biden and it's
been triggering
for donald trump to see that so i will
be covering those and we have so many
other things going on this week leading
up to of course live coverage of the
results just eight days from now
so thanks to everybody who joined me i
don't know that we learned anything new
other than trump is continuing to
brutally attack the english language and
our iqs with these events but i will see
everybody tomorrow
you